and the thing is Exxon is a living thing  so if the head of Exxon if the CEO of  Exxon goes down to Peru with his son and  does some ayahuasca and has an epiphany  and suddenly sees the world as you and I  do and realizes what what's going on and  what his role in that has been and he  goes back to headquarters and has a  meeting on Monday morning saying  gentlemen we need to stop this we can't  do this deepwater drilling we can't be  on the North Slope we have no idea what  we're doing we can't protect the planet  with what's gonna happen he's out he's  out before lunch and what if the Board  of Directors happens to agree with him  they're out what if the whole company  goes and does ayahuasca exactly what  would happen they would all be fired and  other people would replace them because  people don't run companies companies run  people